Hey, so I've been, I guess, struggling with
how to pronounce the name of Joe Biden's White
House press secretary. And I got yet another
voicemail admonishing me about it. Remember,
our voicemail number is two one
nine two David P.. Take a listen.
Hello, David. This is a fan. My name is Sue.
And I mean, this is most kindly way since
you will be pronouncing the White House
press secretary's name hundreds of times.
I was. Suggested to pronounce it correctly. Yes.
Jen Psaki, whether I should know, yes,
a soft A instead of the Sakey, Jen Psaki.
But I so I at the beginning, I would say Jen Psaki
and then a few people wrote to me and said, David,
it's Sukie. So I switched to Psaki. And then over
the weekend I got a dozen emails saying, David,
it's Sakey. And now I'm being told that Sarki
I am going to pronounce it Psaki. And the reason
why is that Jen Psaki recently did an interview
with a longtime friend of hers, and he pronounced
that Psaki I assume he knows how it said.
So I'm going to be pronouncing it Jen Psaki, until
someone explains to me a good reason why I should
reverse course. Once again, we've got a great
bonus show for you today. We've got resignations.
We've got Black History Month drama in Utah
schools. We've got more statements about the
lab hypothesis of the coronavirus.
All of those stories and more on
today's bonus show. Get instant access
by signing up at Join Pakman dot com.